[Music]
welcome to the very first episode of
Kingdom statues where we will go through
my experience in statue collecting and
every statue that you see on this
channel will be in my personal
collection this is I don't work for
store this is not a company where we
purchase statues and resell statues
where we get statues on-loan know
everything in this is my collection
personally as I grow and show you guys
what statues to purchase what statues to
look out for what type of displays that
you would like to put your statues in
and what is the most efficient way and
to utilize your money and going forward
to get the most out of your passion
along my way there was a lot of pitfalls
but there is also a lot of benefits I've
met a ton of great people in this
community and I'm so happy to be part of
it I agonized over this for a couple of
months on trying to figure out which was
the first statue that I would like to
display being that this is the first
episode I wanted to start off with
something that was outstanding a statute
that I felt that represented my
childhood that got me initially hooked
to this great culture and also I wanted
to highlight a company that I feel is
the Kremlin the top-notch companies so
I decided with excellent statute statues
[Music]
iron fist
without further ado I'm gonna be showing
you IFS and all its glory it has to
switch out pieces it has the body that
comes with the full suit and it also has
the bare chest body with the hand that
glows the reason why I choose XM because
I believe the high quality that they
display their items with their statues
are of the highest quality
every last statues comes with a level of
detail and a level of care that you
don't get with every company the paint
applications which you will hear a lot
of on this channel it's top-notch when
paying for a premium statue and Iron
Fist goes for one thousand one hundred
and ninety-nine dollars retail if you
can purchase it secondhand on the
second-hand market and might go for
fifteen hundred if you can get it on
eBay I was fortunate enough to purchase
it from a previous owner and I paid a
decent sum fair market price also when
you purchase with XM they have a
registry you sign up at the website and
you can note who had that statue where
it went to who was the previous owner
and what care they kept it in they can
transfer it over to you so that statue
is in your possession so if anything
unfortunate happens like a theft they
can trace it
so with XM I feel that there's a
well-thought-out
quality that goes along with them also
you get an art print the art print is
absolutely amazing at the same time you
also get a booklet that is highly
detailed on how to put your statue
together
and also how to care for your statue
with information on how to register your
statue
I believe that Exim Studios is the
highest quality that you can get in
studios in this culture we want the best
and I believe XM exceeds and meets that
criteria I am so happy to be doing these
videos I am so happy to give you a peek
into my world please enjoy the videos
like subscribe and give me feedback so I
know how to move forward the format will
change and we will grow together happy
collecting guys and hopefully I can get
a chance to see your collection as you
become the king of statues because guys
everyone is a king in their own
collection
[Music]
[Music]